winning over audiences with his
joyfulness hyper literal language and
sense of loyalty the interstellar
warrior Drax the destroyer is one of the
brightest figures in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you couldn't quite
say the same for his comic book
counterpart in many ways Dave Batista's
interpretation of Drax is barely
recognizable from the character in the
comics and for once that's not a bad
thing since his debut in 1973 is Iron
Man number 55 Drax the destroyer has
gone through drastic shifts in
intelligence temperament and physical
power he's been one of Marvel's most
powerful heroes and he's also been one
of its dumbest he's a character who has
literally lived many lives so the fact
that the Drax of the movies feels like a
completely different person is in
keeping with a long tradition of
reinvention from his quest for vengeance
against Thanos to his surprising
connection to the planet Earth here is
everything you need to know about Drax
the destroyer nothing goes over my head
my reflexes are too fast where I'm from
Drax his origin story appeared in 1974
Captain Marvel number 32 written by jim
Starlin in the issue readers learn about
the heroes homeworld and it's the last
place you'd expect earth as originally
written by Starlin Drax was a human
being by the name of Arthur Douglas who
had a wife named a vet and a daughter
Heather during Thanos his first scouting
mission to earth Arthur and his family
had the bad luck to be on the road in
the Nevada desert as the Titan flew
buying his ship phan o--'s attacked
fatally wounding Arthur and Yvette
unbeknownst to anyone Heather escaped
but will have more to say about her
later after the incident fan owes his
father mentor called out to Kronos
father of the Gods for help in stopping
his wayward son Chronos obliged mentor
and built a super powerful body which he
used as a vessel for Arthur's soul
Arthur Douglas may have been no more but
his soul and sense of vengeance lived on
in a new form Drax
it's a vastly different origin story in
the MCU in guardians of the galaxy Drax
as comic book origins as a human man are
completely ignored instead of Ivette and
Heather he had a wife named Howe that
and a daughter named Kumari Oh both of
them met their ends thanks to Ronan the
accuser acting on orders from Thanos
what were they like
my wife and daughter they were kind
brave true the rewrite of the origin
story is a simple but effective change
the movie version keeps tracks as thirst
for vengeance just without the
complicated wrinkle of extraterrestrial
reincarnation I kind of feel like Jax is
no mine power levels as far as his
strength is concerned the Drax of the
movies as fairly middle-tier you
certainly wouldn't want to arm-wrestle
him but he also better not get on the
Hulk's bad side that wasn't always the
case as the Drax of the comics has
occasionally been one of Marvel's most
powerful superheroes the destroyer has
regularly held his own against the
absolute a list of Marvel tough guys
including Thor the Silver Surfer and the
Hulk along with having a lot more
strength
the Drax of the comics used to have the
power of flight regularly flying through
space without a helmet or spacesuit he
also had the ability to fire powerful
energy blasts from his hands
the Drax of the panels became more like
what we see in the movies in 2005 Drax
the destroyer miniseries after having
one body destroyed in the second issue
Drax was reborn smaller and less
physically powerful but with a much
greater degree of intelligence than the
Vengeance driven brute he used to be
bring me fan OHS even though destroying
Thanos as Drax his sole purpose
he hasn't proven himself to be
particularly good at his job in Drax's
earliest appearances his obsession with
Thanos is so intense that he can be as
much of a liability to the heroes on his
side as a help he cares little about
plans schemes or strategies he simply
throws himself at the mad Titan when he
reappeared after a long absence in 1990s
Silver Surfer number 37 he attacked
everyone in sight screaming where's
Santos over and over not listening or
caring about the fact that no one knew
the answer
in 2006 his annihilation number four
after over three decades of trying and
failing
Drax finally managed to exact his
vengeance against Thanos naturally he
just had to do it while Thanos was
trying to save the galaxy during one of
his rare good-guy turns as Thanos works
to stop the villain Annihilus from
destroying all life in the universe
Drax decides his vengeance is more
important and punches Thanos his heart
out of his chest sure the timing of it
was pretty bad but
can't blame a guy for doing what he was
born to do my daughter moon dragon in
the comics tracks eventually learns that
his daughter Heather survived the attack
in the desert rescued by fan OHS his
father mentor Heather was brought to
Titan and raised there by a group of
powerful monks where she developed the
powers of a super hero taking on the
name moon dragon though moon dragon
would eventually join the Avengers the
defenders the infinity watch and even
the guardians of the galaxy she didn't
always share the most heroic values of
her comrades sometimes she acted
downright evil while traveling through
space with Drax she came across a planet
immersed in war and solved the problem
by mentally enslaving all the
inhabitants to help her swayed his
daughter to take another course of
action Drax contacted the Avengers for
help along with a mind-controlled Thor
moon dragon fought against Drax and
succeeded in defeating him it was the
ultimate injustice he was felled by his
own daughter and didn't even really
deserve it
as you might imagine Drax and Moon
dragons relationship has been pretty
strained ever since the idiot when Drax
returned to life in Silver Surfer number
35 his mind wasn't fully healed though
still intent on securing Thanos his
destruction the intergalactic warrior
came back a little more loveable in a
whole whole lot dumber Drax is
diminished iq was used for comedic
purposes with his brute strength and odd
passions being mined for Laughs when I
had a warlock arrives to recruit Drax
for a new team Drax is busy smashing TV
monitors because he's angry the
transmission of the earth show Alf has
been interrupted Drax is mine didn't
stay dull forever but his intelligence
wasn't restored fully in a way that's
stuck until 2005 Strax the destroyer
miniseries no matter what intelligence
level he's been at though he's always
remembered how to play a mean sax a
cosmic custodian the conclusion of the
Infinity Gauntlet story left the
gauntlet and it's six gems under the
guardianship of Adam warlock Marvel's
cosmic Pantheon wasn't happy with this
arrangement however and encouraged him
to share the burden keeping the soul gem
for himself Adam chose five people to be
the guardians of the remaining gems
creating a team known as the Infinity
watch
warlock would later wonder if he had
made the right decisions with the people
he chose to carry the gems fearing the
influence of the Infinity Gauntlet had
corrupted his judgment it's no surprise
why he thought this he gave the space
gym to the mischievous pip the troll who
immediately used it to steal among other
things an Avengers Quinn jet the mind
gym went to moon dragon a woman you'll
recall once used her powers to enslave
an entire world the reality gem went to
Thanos of all people finally Adam gave
the power gym to Drax the dim-witted
brute who destroys things when he misses
an episode of Alf good leadership Adam
famously huge the movie Drax is an alien
while the comic book Drax is an
earthling who is forced into a
constructed body this naturally means
there are a number of differences
between them one of the more surprising
differences well there's a specific
bodily function comic-book tracks
doesn't have to worry about in the
beginning of guardians of the galaxy vol
2 rocket threatens to fill up Peter
Quill's pillow with fecal matter while
he sleeps because that's the kind of
mature and responsible team the
guardians are put your turd in my bed I
shave you won't be my turn it'll be
Drax's believe it or not this is an
invention specific to the movies in the
comics the size of Drax is bowel
movements isn't any sort of legend as it
turns out he doesn't have them at all in
warlock in the infinity watch number 2
when Adam warlock gives Drax the power
Jim Drax doesn't know what to do with it
thinking he's been handed two jellybeans
he promptly eats it understandably
Gamora freaks out and warlock tries to
reassure her reminding her that the gym
is indestructible and won't digest when
she continues to protest warlock says
Drax his physical being is unlike most
creatures I'll explain later
trust me he won't lose it in other words
the Drax of the comic books doesn't poop
no wonder he seems so much happier in
the movies thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]